what's up everybody dr. Mike here I'm
incredibly excited to announce that this
week's video is officially all-natural
check this out
impressive right and you know what that
means no you don't I don't either
doesn't mean anything this week I'm
going to be talking about misleading
food labels and my top 10 tips on how to
be a more educated consumer number 10
don't buy into the meaningless phrases
all natural foods can still contain
chemicals even the FDA website doesn't
have a formal definition of all-natural
plus even if something is fully
all-natural it still doesn't mean it's
healthy your energy drink could contain
more caffeine than you think and that's
courtesy of the Goron abeam which
contains two to three times more
caffeine than the coffee bean and energy
drink companies don't have to add that
to the caffeine content on the can
because it's part of their proprietary
blend you see low fat on nutrition label
and you automatically assume it must be
healthy first of all you shouldn't be so
scared of dietary fat and second of all
most of these companies just jack up the
sugar content to make up for the lost
taste not so healthy right your Bacon's
has no added nitrates
it must be preservative free not so fast
if it contains something like celery
root powder that's just another form of
added nitrates that's how they get you
[Music]
your food tastes really sweet but the
label says zero grams of sugar how is
that possible well it's likely that
you're ingesting artificial sweeteners
like aspartame and while we don't have
absolute evidence that is bad for your
health what we do know now is it does
change your brain chemistry and make you
crave more unhealthy foods throughout
the day you're halfway there to the
number-one point that will make you an
educated consumer zero grams of sugar
added it's a great thing but you still
need to check the nutrition facts for
the naturally occurring sugar for
example if you have a cup of orange
juice in the morning made up of four
oranges that's thirty-six grams of sugar
same as a coke but guess what the label
will still say zero grams of added sugar
don't fall for these unsubstantiated
health claims you often find our food
packaging it boosts your immunity it
helps your skin stay radiant most of
these health claims are often vague or
exaggerated in fact the Journal of
nutrition education and behavior valley
these claims appeared mostly on foods
high in saturated fats sugars or sodium
just stick to Nutrition Facts and the
ingredient list also be skeptical when
the packaging touts a single ingredient
usually that's just a sleight-of-hand
move to distract you from the other
unhealthy ingredients found elsewhere
whole-wheat cereals whole wheat bars
whole wheat bread you think you're
getting a true whole-wheat product not
so fast you have to look at the first
ingredient in the ingredient section
which is the most abundant one and it
has to have the word whole in order for
it to be made predominantly of whole
wheat number dish dosa
the light that sounds like a great
quality for your food to have light
means low in fat low in calories right
not necessarily if a food tastes light
if it's light in color it can still
carry the light label so don't get too
excited when you see it light in the
title of your food the number one tip
yes the number one tip to make you an
educated food consumer look at the
serving size I've made this mistake so
many times I've gotten a container of
soup and I said oh in a slightly more
sodium than I thought and then I ate it
and then I realized the serving size was
a quarter of the container so that means
I had four times the amount of sodium I
initially had now look you get an ice
cream container and it says 120 calories
per half a cup how many half a cups are
in your bowl of ice cream the FDA is
even catching on to this one if the
entire container is likely to be eaten
in one sitting the companies will be
obligated to put the entire container as
a serving size so there you have it you
are now an educated food consumer please
don't stress about your food choices
because stress is a true killer be smart
educate yourself know what you put in
your body and stay healthy thanks for
watching seven your Bacon's will guess
what why I keep saying well guess what
number nine why am i doing six
[Music]